in a previous video we talked about
trying to estimate a population mean
with a sample mean and then constructing
a confidence interval about that sample
mean and we talked about different
scenarios we could use Z table plus the
true population standard deviation and
that actually would construct pretty
valid confidence intervals but the
problem is you don't know the population
standard deviation and so you might try
to use a Z table to find your critical
values plus the sample standard
deviation but what we talked about is
that this doesn't actually do a good job
of calculating our confidence intervals
and we're going to see that
experimentally in a few seconds and so
instead we have something called a t
statistic where if we want our critical
value we use a t table instead of a Z
table and then we use that in
conjunction with our sample standard
deviation and then all of a sudden we
are actually going to have pretty good
confidence intervals to make this a
little bit more real let's look at a
simulation so this is a scratch pad on
Khan Academy made by Khan Academy user
charlotte allen and the whole point
there is to see what our confidence
intervals look like with these different
scenarios so let's say we have a true
population mean of 2.0 for some let's
say it's the average number the mean
number of apples people eat a day the
true population mean is 2 that seems
high but maybe it's in a certain country
that has a lot of apples and let's say
we know that the population standard
deviation is 0.5 and we're going to
create confidence intervals with the
goal of having a 95% confidence level
and we're going to take sample sizes of
12 so first we can construct our
confidence intervals using Z and Sigma
which is a legitimate way to do it and
so let's just draw a bunch of samples
here and so we do see that it looks like
it is roughly 95% when we keep making
these samples and constructing these
confidence intervals that 95% of the
time these confidence intervals contain
our true population mean so these look
like a good confidence intervals but
what we've talked about is normally when
you're doing this type of thing this
type of inferential statistics you don't
know the population standard deviation
you don't know Sigma so in
said we off you might be tempted to use
Z with our sample standard deviations
but if you look at that for these exact
same samples we just calculated notice
now when we did it over and over again
we've done this 625 times in this
scenario where we keep calculating the
confidence intervals with Z and s the
true population mean is contained in the
intervals only ninety two point two
percent of the time and we could keep
going so if we have a much lower hit
rate than we would hope to have if we
were actually using Z and Sigma now
what's neat is if we use T use a T's
table notice this is getting much closer
and this is neat because with the T
table and something that we can actually
get from the sample the sample standard
deviation we're actually getting able to
have a pretty close hit rate to what we
would have if we actually knew the
population standard deviation so that's
the value of T and T statistics and
we're going to give more and more
examples including using a T table in
future videos